[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' à tanis
d'interdire on va débuter cette émission
avec les oem salem et vassan berthé qui
est à nancy les deux auteurs du livre
les nouveaux oracles comment les
algorithmes prédisent le crime je
recevrai ensuite marc fraises le génial
créateur de monsieur fraize qui revient
avec madame fraises à tout nouveau
spectacle au théâtre du rond-point et
bientôt en tournée en france éric mouton
qui est libraire et expert en bande
dessinée qui fait partie des 170
exposants du salon du livre rare et d
expert en objets d'art qui ouvre ses
portes demain au champ de mars et l'on
commence tout de suite par les oem salem
et vassan berthet voici l'image que vous
avez choisie pour illustrer ce début de
xxième siècle sur des caméras de
surveillance
des eaux bonjour tradori taddei merci de
nous recevoir donc absolument on a
choisi cette image de caméras de
surveillance
alors nous on est sur un livre qui parle
de la prédiction du crime de
l'utilisation des nouvelles technologies
pour les services régaliens donc la
police la justice les services de
renseignement et on entre dans une ère
que d'autres chercheurs ont pu qualifier
d' air de la surveillance puisque on est
à une heure où on peut collecter un
maximum de donner à voir une quantité
formidable de données et les exploités
grâce à l'augmentation de nos capacités
de calcul est donc avec vincent berthet
nous posons cette question de savoir si
ces outils sont efficaces s'ils sont
utiles et dans quelle mesure ils sont
attentatoires aux libertés publiques et
donc quel équilibre quelle ligne de
crête ne pouvant trouver collectivement
vincent berthet
oui tout à fait je pense que c'est u2
c'est une image qui résume bien notre
propos dans ce livre il ya une
formidable
éclosion technologies prédictives
aujourd'hui qui peuvent être utilisés en
particulier à des fins de sécurité que
ce soit dans la police ou dans la
justice ces nouveaux oracles qui renvoie
auprès cox dans la fiction minority
report aujourd'hui ce sont plus d ce
sont plus d entité mystérieuse fictive
ce sont des algorithmes nourrie par des
intelligences artificielles de plus en
plus
précises et donc la question comme le
souligne mon co auteur léo c'est de les
encadrer plutôt que de les subir et
nouveaux oracles est paru aux éditions
du cnrs
on se souvient de minority report le
film de spielberg
d'après le roman de philip k dick ou la
police arrête les criminels avant même
qu'ils commettent un crime on n'en est
pas là mais les algorithmes prédictifs
utilisé par la police et par la justice
sont un premier pas votre avis versa
en tout cas ils sont vendus comme tel
alors on n'en est pas tout à fait là
mais la promesse est là la promesse de
philip k dick dans minority report c'est
en 2054 à washington une société sans
crime et donc on a cette prétention de
penser que tout comportement humain
étant prédictible avec suffisamment de
données finalement il ne reste plus qu'à
collecter des données à les traiter de
mieux en mieux pour arriver à une
société sans crime ou en tout cas une
société où va réduire le crime une
société on réduira le crime on réduira
le crime drastiquement puisqu'en fait on
pourra le prédire et donc je pense quand
même que le meilleur exemple de cette
fiction qui est aujourd'hui rattrapé par
la réalité c'est l'allégorie c'est le
logiciel près de paul en californie qui
prétend prédire les lieux où vont se
produire des crimes alors ça c'est sur
l'aspect police commençons par l'aspect
justice l'aller les algorithmes
prédictifs sont utilisés comment et
pourquoi
vassan berthe est alors tout à fait ils
sont utilisés principalement aux états
unis en france on est encore très loin
pour pour plein de raisons ils sont
utilisés notamment pour les décisions de
mise en détention provisoire dans l'état
du new jersey par exemple qui a été un
des premiers états pour les utiliser
donc ces algorithmes en fait il
fonctionne là ça sent la façon suivante
vous avez un prévenu qui passe devant le
juge et le juge va décider si en
attendant le procès y mais il place le
prévenu en détention provisoire ce qu'on
a c'est des algorithmes qui vont passer
en revue qui vont passer à la moulinette
des millions de cas d'espèce similaire
des millions de cas similaires au cas
d'espèce et qui vont sur la base d'une
analyse statistique estimer le risque
que le prévenu récidive s'il est remis
en liberté donc ce sont des outils d
aide à la décision et c'est un point
important parce que ses algorithmes ne
se substitue pas aux juges mais il lui
apporte une aide d'une recommandation
statistiques que le juge peut utilement
utilisé dans sa décision de placer deux
prévenus en détention provisoire ou non
alors là c'est pour la mise en détention
provisoire mais ça fonctionne de la même
manière comme aide à la décision pour la
libération conditionnelle de la même
façon est-ce qu'on permet à un début de
sortir de prison va calculer les risques
qui vérifie div mais aussi pour la
détermination de la peine pour les mêmes
raisons exactement
en france
ce qui nous en empêche pour l'instant
c'est qu'on n'a pas assez de données en
fait ce serait ça qu'ils sont
disponibles l'open data est pas le même
sens oui l'open data est pas le nom et
en france alors le frein est plus que
pratique il est tout simplement
juridique c'est-à-dire que dans le
système judiciaire français il n'est
absolument pas concevable aujourd'hui de
juger un prévenu sur la base d'une
anticipation quand bien même cette
anticipation est rationné la statistique
sur sur sur une base purement
statistique endroits on a vraiment sa
tradition que bon juge ex post tout
juste ici à peu ne peut être jugé que
exposé et donc pas exemptes et sur le
fondement d'une prédiction donc à la
limite en france elle est davantage
structurelles juridique plutôt que
technique alors est ce que est ce que ça
marche est-ce que c'est efficace est ce
que parce qu'après tout les juges quand
ils décident d'une mise en liberté
conditionnelle ou d'une détention
provisoire il fonde la prédiction eux
aussi mais est-ce que la prédiction des
algorithmes marche mieux que la
prédiction humaine
sans berthet oui tout à fait alors du
coup nous dans notre livre c'est
exactement neuf points d'entrée crc de
comparer l'efficacité en premier lieu de
l'expert que ce soit un juge un médecin
radiologue etc et l'efficacité de la
machine de l'algorithme et les travaux
en psychologie cognitive en sciences
cognitives montre que en moyenne la
prédiction la précision de la prédiction
algorithmique et supérieure à celle de
l'humain parce qu'il ya une erreur
humaine il ya une coupe il ya une allée
à dents dans l'appréciation humaine
lorsqu'il donnait là les âges judiciaire
en justice et c'est précisément pour
cette raison pour ce pragmatisme qu aux
etats unis ces algorithmes ont connu un
essor depuis une vingtaine d'années mais
est-ce que avec les algorithmes on reste
plus longtemps en prison qu'avec la
décision humaine l'algorithme a priori
est plus sévère enfin sévère c'est pas
lui qui juge mais disons que les et en
général ils attribuent des chances de
récidive supérieur à scorer attribué à
un juge alors justement il permet
d'éviter l'écueil de lesquin humain très
humain d'ailleurs de surestimer les
chances de
récidive le risque de récidive et ses
algorithmes permettent un double
avantage ce qui a été montré
statistiquement dans les juridictions
américaines c'est que je permet de
désengorger les prisons parce qu'ils
estiment mieux le risque faible de
récidive des de la plupart des prévenus
et il améliore en même temps la sécurité
parce que il estime mieux le risque pour
le coup des individus réellement
dangereux donc d'un côté ils désengorger
les prisons et d'un autre côté il
améliore la sécurité publique c'est
marrant parce qu'en fait ils font le
contraire de ce qu on pourrait supposer
on pourrait supposer quand on est jugé
par un algorithme sera jugée plus
sévèrement
alors qu'en fait c'est le contraire je
pense que c'est une présuppositions qui
est liée à la façon dont on voit les
algorithmes et on les voit en fait comme
des outils mathématiques et finalement
froid implacable là où au contraire le
juge serait plus humain ce que montre
vincent berthet est ce qu'il disait à
l'instant c'est que finalement ça ne se
vérifie pas dans les faits et donc il
parlait des juridictions américaines on
peut aussi parler de certaines
juridictions canadiennes qui ont
expérimenté des algorithmes et qui ont
eu des résultats assez similaire oui et
donc désengorger les prisons parce qu'un
fond le l'algorithme sait qui a peu de
criminels qui récidivent la plupart des
criminels ne récidive pas donc lui
mathématiquement il en tient corps et
donc il ya des tas de gens qui ne passe
pas par la case prison ou en tout cas
très peu de temps pour cette raison-là
absolument et je pense qu'il ya un point
intéressant dans ce que vous disiez il
ya quelques minutes vous vous rappeliez
que finalement le l'algorithme de
disposer des mêmes informations que le
juge pourtant donc ils basent leur
décision sur les mêmes éléments et c'est
d'ailleurs je pense que on reviendra
éventuellement dessus mais c'est
d'ailleurs une décision de la cour
suprême du wisconsin en 2013 dans la
sphère loomis contre wisques en chine où
un prévenu s'était vu refuser une remise
en liberté conditionnelle et avait donc
attaquer vraiment sur le principe même
de l'algorithme en disant j'ai été
soumis à une décision qui est froide et
qui est arbitraire parce qu'elle a été
prise par une machine et la cour suprême
luis quand il n'avait pas été dans son
sens et elle avait au contraire conclut
que l'algorithme disposant des mêmes
éléments que le juge n'est pas du tout
de rupture du principe d'égalité par
rapport à d'autres jugements et que en
fait il s'agissait de deux boîtes noires
on donne à un juge d information son
cerveau est une boîte noire et ont donné
un algorithme d information il fait du
machine learning donc il déduit des
régles de l'art et des statistiques des
bases de données qui l'exploitent et
c'est aussi donc pour nous une boîte
noire alors revenons-en à la police
prédictive la police prédictive on lui
demande doit en tout cas c'est ce
qu'elle nous vend enfin les algorithmes
de police prédictive nous dit on peut
prédire les crimes
les types de délinquance on peut prédire
aussi le type de délinquants et les
victimes probables de la même manière on
pourrait aussi dire s'est il ya toutes
les chances que le prochain crimes
qu'ils aient lieu là celui là c'est
beaucoup de promesses à la faveur
seulement donc on en revient exactement
1 minority report c'est tout l'enjeu
d'ailleurs ce n'est pas un hasard si ces
technologies là sont nés dans la dans
l'université de ucla à westwood et donc
on est vraiment au croisement de
hollywood et donc de cette promesse de
la science fiction de prédire et dans la
silicon valley là où il ya vraiment le
l'écosystème tech et américains qui
permet de voir émerger ce genre de
technologie donc ce genre de technologie
elle est basée sur la théorie des
répliques en fait ça vient de la
sismologie déjà il est très compliqué de
prédire où un séisme va se produire en
revanche une fois qu'un séisme s'est
produit statistiquement en et en
exploitant toutes les informations qu'on
a sur les séismes précédent on sait très
bien quels vont être les répliques
quelle va être leur puissance et où
elles vont se produire et le docteur
branching gamme de ucla y de
l'université de los angeles qui a mis au
point ce système là s'est dit que de la
même façon le comportement humain était
prédictible donc ils ont équipé les
forces de police d'un certain nombre de
villes ou de compter américain de
logiciels qui se base sur d'immenses
base de données recensant la criminalité
passé et aussi sur un certain nombre
d'autres indicateurs
qui permettent de déduire des
régularités dans le comportement humain
et je pense qu'ils avaient une très
bonne formule du chef de la police de
modesto qui utilisaient ce logiciel là
et on était très satisfait et disait que
les cambrioleurs qu'il le sache ou
venons suivent une logique mathématique
donc finalement on pourrait les doubler
en étant plus malin que puisque nous on
a la formule mathématique dont on peut
déduire comment est-ce qu'ils vont agir
en suivant cette logique où il m'attend
là j'y arrive actuellement absolument
donc où ils vont agir le logiciel près
de paul je crois que c'était le logiciel
près de paul qui a une publicité aux
états unis très à l'américaine on voyait
un criminel préparé son coup mettre sa
cagoule est arrivé sur les lieux où ils
allaient commettre son méfait où
l'attendait un shérif américain en train
de boire un café qui le salut et sachant
déjà où va se produire le crime oui donc
la promesse et oui mais alors on voit
bien et dieu sait si on prête des super
pouvoirs à l'hyperpuissance américaine
mais on sait aussi que la nsa par
exemple qui coûte le monde entier
disposent donc collecte à nombre de deux
des phénomènes al en matière de
prévision d' acte terroriste par exemple
série d c'est dérisoire vous en parlez
dans votre livre en fait on avait
annoncé qu'ils avaient en empêcher
toutes sortes d'attentât ou début on
avait fini par dire on en a trouvé 13 et
puis ça a descendu et à la fin il y en a
un la nsa ça a servi à déjouer un acte
terroriste d'après ce que ce que dit
votre livre alors donc ce serait ça
serait vraiment ça mériterait pas ce que
ça coûte alors sur l'efficacité de ces
systèmes vous avez raison de poser la
question parce que finalement le prisme
sur lequel il faut prendre ces
problématiques là c'est vraiment la
question du coût et de l'efficacité le
coup il est sociétale il est est ce
qu'on peut espionner la population est
ce qu'on peut utiliser des systèmes
comme les algorithmes et l'efficacité
donc il faut la prouver il suffit pas à
faire une feinte de faire de la
publicité et de faire des films de
science fiction pour justifier l'usagé
de ces algorithmes sur l'algorithme près
de paul il ya eu un rapport de
l'inspection générale de la police de
los angeles le lan chili en mars
2010neuf où il concluait que il ne
pouvait pas prouver l'efficacité du
logiciel en fonction des données qu'ils
avaient ils avaient quand même un
certain nombre de données et c'est la
ville signe de cette ce logiciel et il
se trouve que l'an dernier le ls bédié a
cessé d'utiliser près de paul donc une
façon de penser que près de paul c'était
finalement une prédiction des banalités
le livre ici savent très bien où les
crimes se commettent habituellement et
que là où ils ont été hier et ils ont
interrompu un trafic de stupéfiants
qu'ils y reviennent aujourd'hui et de
bonnes chances que il retrouve une
situation des lakers au criminel sur
laquelle ils pourront agir sur
l'utilisation des algorithmes dans le
domaine du renseignement c'est un petit
peu différent alors les travaux que vous
mentionniez sont des travaux d'un
chercheur du cnrs expert grégoire
chamayou et qui démontrait que les
algues reine de la msa alors c'était je
crois jusqu'en 2017 qui est comme ça
avait permis finalement d'arrêter très
peu d'attenté
il c'est difficile de dire exactement ce
qui relève
de deux informations qui ont
effectivement été obtenus par des
domaines techniques et des domaines
humain est en réalité les américains
utilisent les deux et donc il peut y
avoir une certaine complémentarité
je vais vous donner un exemple les
algorithmes utilisés par les
renseignements américains permettent
d'identifier un certain nombre de
profils qui ont un fort taux de
ressemblance avec les profils terroriste
connu ça veut pas dire forcément qu on a
affaire à un terrorisme ensuite ces
données là peuvent être transmises à des
unités je pense par exemple le vieil à
une excellente unité d'analysé
comportementale qui s'appelle billets ue
et ce sont des profilers qui vont
regarder ensuite les profils voir
lesquelles sont susceptibles de passer à
l'acte voir s'il va y avoir une erreur
et ce qui est intéressant c'est patent
de substituer aux agents de terrain des
algorithmes travaillent ensemble
absolument c'est d'identifier un certain
nombre de profils pour ensuite
donner à l'expertisé humaine sa chance
de d'exploiter cette information donc
c'est à la fois la collecte du
renseignement et son analyse vincent
berthet est-ce qu'on peut empêcher un
crime de se produire votre aviv
on peut
on est très loin de minority report mais
on peut estimer de plus en plus
avec de plus en plus de précision les
chances qui se produisent il ya cette
citation qu'on débute le chapitre sur le
sur la plus prédictive en citant le
l'ancien chef du à l'épi dit charlie
beck qui disait ce qui compte n'est pas
le nombre de criminels que vous arrêter
mais le nombre de crimes que vous
empêchez derrière cette cette phrase un
peu marre quand il ya cette notion que
effectivement pour tout un ensemble de
raisons il est préférable pour la
société d'empêcher qu'un crime se
produise
plutôt que d'intervenir une fois que ce
crime s'est produit et on pense que
c'est que pour le mieux avec la
meilleure façon d'empêcher les crimes de
se produire c'est justement d'enfermer
les gens qui en ont déjà commis
exactement exactement c'est la même
musique et c'est la raison pour laquelle
ces logiciels algorithmiques de
prédiction des crimes sont génère autant
d'intérêt mais les les
leur efficacité
est en décalage avec ses attentes d'où
ce que disait mon collègue est là où les
déceptions qu'ils peuvent qui peuvent
produire parce que à ce jour
effectivement lors leurs capacités de
prédiction n'est pas à la hauteur de ce
qu'on voudrait obtenir voudrais savoir
aujourd'hui à dans tel endroit à telle
heure va se produire tels crimes mais
aujourd'hui on est encore très loin de
pouvoir faire ça celle ci sur
le problème que c'est nous posent tous
ces algorithmes c est ce qu ils sont
compatibles avec le droit avec le
respect des libertés fondamentales
qu'elle est quel est votre conclusion
dans ce livre après après avoir
travaillé sur ce sujet alors danse ligne
on a cherché une a exploré vraiment une
ligne de crête et je pense que le terme
ils douanes celle équilibre et donc
comment trouver cet équilibre donc on
est encore dans un calcul avec vincent
verte et on a identifié quand même le
fait qu'en france on a un problème dans
le positionnement et qu'en fait on a un
positionnement qui est soit dans le seau
luccioni sme technologique où on croit
dans la formule mathématique et on pense
que donc il faut les utiliser c'est
efficace et donc finalement peu importe
la liberté puisque c'est efficace où ce
sera de plus en plus efficaces ou ce
sera de plus en plus délicat c'est ça
qu'on dit de toute façon c'est lui avec
la têt les gens' artificiel mais
aujourd'hui plus vite que le hamas est
guéri de mon fric à une efficacité on
arrivera à minority report et donc ça
vaut la peine finalement on vit dans une
société sans crime ça vaut la peine
d'essayer ou à l inverse il ya ceux qui
sont effrayés par les nouvelles
technologies et qui les refusent en bloc
une forme de ludisme français à vouloir
refuser la technologie ce prétexte qu à
nouveau on est dans des robes au froid
etc nous on a cherché à étudier donc le
coût et l'efficacité de chacun de ces
systèmes là alors comme on le disait par
exemple pour la police prédictive
l'efficacité n'est pas avéré donc
finalement le coup n'en vaut pas
forcément la peine et ce il ya eu des
expérimentations en france elles n'ont
pas été concluantes donc on n'a pas
adopté jusqu'au bout cette logique
prédictive nous ce qu'on pense c'est
qu'il faut donc choisir les systèmes
qu'on va utiliser vincent aura peut-être
un mode dans un instant sur le privacy
by design sur le fait vraiment de
choisir les bons systèmes ceux qui
répondent à nos besoins
deuxièmement je pense qu'il faut un
débat public avant de les utiliser donc
on va rentrer dans une période
électorale ça sera important aussi qu'on
puisse dire aux français voilà quelles
sont les nouvelles technologies est ce
qu'on peut améliorer l'état avec ça et
ensuite ya un certain nombre de
garanties à mettre en oeuvre il ya un
principe de proportionalité déjà donc
c'est à dire qu'on n'utilise pas ces
systèmes là pour absolument tout un
exemple très simple celui de la
reconnaissance faciale on l'a
expérimenté dans deux lycées sous
l'égide de la cnil en 2019
la cnil conclu que ces 10 et efficace
hein on reconnaît bien les étudiants
mais la conclusion de la cnil c'est que
c'est disproportionné en atteinte aux
libertés et qu'un simple contrôle par
badge suffirait donc on revient quand
même à quelque chose d'assez simple
al'inverse on a pu prouver en tout cas
des chercheurs américains ont prouvé
qu'il était possible d'identifier des
terroristes basés sur l'expérience de
l'attentât du marathon de boston un
algorithme aurait pu trouver en quelques
heures
le nom de sarah nayef qu'il a fallu deux
jours à la police américaine pour
trouver ça vaut peut-être la peine de le
faire avec les bonnes gars entier ces
bonnes garanties sont un contrôle
administratif efficace celui de la cnil
par exemple ou de la cnct est requis et
cette commission nationale sur les
techniques de recueil du renseignement
qui a été créée par la loi du 24 juillet
avec les garanties juridictionnelle
suffisante un contrôle du juge
constitutionnel un contrôle du juge
administratif et enfin un contrôle aussi
et c'est peut-être ce qui pêche en
france un contrôle parlementaire accrue
vincent berthet
oui alors c'est une question qui est
qu'on essaie d'aborder un en substance
dans le livre la question de fond que
vous posiez cds que est-ce que c'est ces
méthodes parce que cette logique un peu
minority report elle est soluble dans le
droit on a des éléments de réponse dans
la jurisprudence du conseil
constitutionnel si vous prenez par
exemple une disposition qui était prévu
par la loi anti casseurs qui prévoyait
de fournir au préfet la possibilité
d'interdire à certaines personnes de
manifester à ce qu'on appelait le
filtrage individuelle des manifestants
le conseil constitutionnel a clairement
indiqué que telle mesure était
attentatoire aux droits fondamentaux en
particulier le droit de manifester donc
aujourd'hui ces mesures est se prêtent
elles sont peu solubles dans le droit
français heureusement quelque part mais
la question de fond c'est au final quel
quel compromis ont choisi entre entre la
sécurité et la liberté entre
l'efficacité et la liberté et donc toute
la question comme le souligne et les oem
salem c'est où est ce qu on place le
curseur douce le ce qu'on met en avant
c'est d'éviter un écueil d'une position
de principe et dans un sens ou dans
l'autre c'est à dire que aux seuls prêts
au seul motif qu'une technologie
pourrait faire peser un risque sur la
liberté ont la balle et on l'a balayé
d'un revers de la main
on pense que cette position n'est pas
fructueuse et elle est dangereuse en
réalité pour l'avenir parce que au
lendemain des attentats 2015 ce qui
s'est passé c'est qu'en fait la société
palan tir a conclu un accord avec la dg
ainsi donc ce qu'ils montrent que si on
adopte des positions de principes trop
forte mais que la réalité nous rattrape
et que le pragmatisme nous rattrape
également on est obligé de s'en remettre
à ses solutions donc le la ligne que
l'on préconise c'est une ligne
pragmatique qui consiste à mettre en
balance des avantages que nous procurent
ces technologies
avec leurs inconvénients et de trouver
une position française parce que la
france a une tradition des droits de
l'homme que l'on ne peut pas non plus
balayé d'un revers de la main mais que
l'on peut concilier avec les avantages
que nous procurent ces technologies
quand on parle aux fiches et s par
exemple qui sont des gens qui n'ont pas
commis d'attentât dit de crime d'aucune
sorte mais que l'on dont tout sur
lesquels on a fait des prédictions
disant ça pourrait arriver il ya plus de
chance avec eux qu'avec d'autres temps
qu'on se contente de les surveiller sans
qu'il le sache même s'ils le savent tant
qu'on se contente de les surveiller
c'est une chose mais un certain nombre
d'hommes politiques est généralement
après chaque attentat voudrait qu'on les
enferme oubliant par là même caillou qui
n'ont encore rien fait et et là ça
deviendrait problématique que quand on
se réfère par exemple ce que l'on fait
peut-être déjà d'ailleurs à des
algorithmes prédictifs pour décider qui
va être fichés health ou pas
seulement alors non
613 vous vous souvenez au lendemain de
d2 l'épisode
de l'assassinât de samuel pâtit la
ministre de l'intérieur gérard darmanin
avait précisément déclaré sur un plateau
télé que l'état de droit ce n'est pas
minority report parce que il ya au
lendemain d'un attentat au lendemain
d'un acte terroriste il ya toujours
cette critique qui revient de on aurait
pu savoir on aurait pu anticiper donc on
aurait pu agir avant et donc se pose la
question des fichiers se pose bien cette
ce problème de de minority report c'est
à dire que est-ce qu'on est ce qu'on
passe à l'acte avant est ce qu'on a ce
qu'on enferme à titre préventif mais
dans ce cas se pose la question des
droits fondamentaux et du camp de
concentration par la même occasion
puisqu'il offrait bien qu'il ya enfin
pas le 1er mai le plus célèbre avoir
enfermé des gens sous prétexte qu'il
représentait éventuellement à danger
c'est adolf hitler nous on appelle quand
même à se méfier de cette logique qui
vise à passer de la notion de
culpabilité à celle de dangerosité la
dangerosité d'un individu ne peut pas et
en l'état du droit français ne peut
absolument pas justifié son internement
préventif en revanche en revanche pour
les personnes qui aurait déjà commis un
crime c'est devenu possible et c'est un
peu un tournant dans le droit français
il ya une loi en 2008 sur la rétention
de sûreté qui fait que quelqu'un qui
aurait
effectué sa peine pour des crimes
extrêmement graves de les crimes de sang
quelqu'un qui aurait effectué sa peine
et donc serait libre selon droit
français peut être maintenu en détention
mais pour d'autres raisons c'est pas
seulement parce qu'on craint qu'ils
récidivent il ya ça mais il ya aussi
parce qu'on veut le punir
davantage il ya l'idée qu'il revienne
dans la société où il a commis un crime
monstrueux nous paraît quand même
insupportable politiquement peut-être
naturellement le droit français même
trois noms et ses 105 sur le devant d'un
an
revanche à coeur mais c'est une des
raisons de la loi de rétention c'était
aussi de dire on peut pas admettre
qu'ils reviennent ensuite comme si de
rien n'était politiquement c'est une
possibilité maintenant cette logique en
fait pour les personnes qui sortent elle
est en train d'être étendue et en
particulier il ya eu des tentatives l'an
dernier de d'une loi en 2020 qui a été
censuré par le conseil constitutionnel
sur le fait de maintenir des mesures
justes alors tous les ans pendant une
période qui pouvaient s'étendre jusqu'à
une dizaine d'années ça a été censurée
cette année une nouvelle loi a permis de
mettre en place dès mi case des mesures
individuelles de contrôle administratif
et de surveillance qui dure qui devait
durer jusqu'à deux ans le conseil
constitutionnel a ramené à 12 mois donc
ça montre que en france on cherche
c'était cet équilibre entre la sécurité
et la liberté entre la dangerosité la
culpabilité et c'est le conseil
constitutionnel qui fixent cette ligne
de crête qui jusqu'àlors paraît quand
même assez vite assez équilibré les
nouveaux oracles c'est paru aux éditions
du cnrs comment les algorithmes
prédisent le crime merci à tous les deux
d'être venu en parler dans interdit
d'interdire on fait une pause on se
retrouve juste après avec marc fraises
at fraises vous étiez venu dès les
débuts de interdit d'interdire pour
parler de monsieur fraize spectacle que
vous avez peaufiné pendant de très
nombreuses années jusqu'à en faire un
petit chef-d'oeuvre acclamé et par la
critique et par le public ce qui est
toujours mieux aujourd'hui vous créez
madame fraises on va en parler dans un
instant mais regarde d'abord l'image que
vous avez choisi pour symboliser notre
époque et cette image
là voici voilà c'est une très belle
photo sébastien marchal qui opèrent à la
réunion et que j'avais rencontrée dans
un beau théâtre à saint denis
oui parce que c'est une époque
qui se prête aussi à se rappeler qu'il
ya des gens qui prennent du plaisir
encore aujourd'hui qui rit qui sont
heureux et bon là le hasard fait que ces
trois femmes enfin je crois mais mais
voilà j'ai envie de
de regarder un petit peu mon époque
comme ça ça ça fait du bien elle regarde
quand même un téléphone portable un
boutre aux femmes ouais ça se trouve
c'est les mines c'est votre émission oui
peut-être et donc ça va et c'est vrai
que ça fait rire parfois
vous créez donc que madame fraises au
théâtre du rond point c'est jusqu'au 17
octobre du jeudi au dimanche 7 à 18h30
vous partira ensuite en tournée en
france vous séparer de monsieur fraize
ça a été douloureux oui je me suis
séparée de lui je vais très bien
annoncer les dernières ont été dans ce
théâtre que j'aime beaucoup qui et les
européens mais
mais il se raccroche à moi quand je suis
sur scène en madame je le veux je le
vois se rappeler à mon bon souvenir bon
c'est pas désagréable mais il faudra
quand même que je lui dise d'aller se
reposer définitivement oui pourquoi ce
qu'il faut il faut véritablement passer
à autre chose ah oui parce que le
personnage offre d'autres options et
d'autre
recherche qui
m'intéresse beaucoup aujourd'hui donc
voilà forcément 20 ans à des temps un
petit peu pour l'instant c'est pas grave
mais mais l'objectif c'est de ces d'être
pleinement dans ce nouveau personnage
alors ce nouveau personnage on va on va
le voir en photo vous êtes en femme il
traverse travestir en femme tous les
acteurs sur tous les acteurs comiques
l'ont fait c'est une sorte de passage
obligé
mais jouer un homme qui s'habille en
femme et jouer une femme c'est pas la
même chose
non c'est sûr là il n'y a jamais eu si
évident d'aborder ce thème de un petit
peu de moi et je les cache début je me
suis dit il joue une femme c'est une
femme madame fraises et après je me suis
mis au fond ce n'est peut-être pas en
fait c'est ça que j'ai envie de créer
c'est cette ambiguïté cette espèce
d'identité pas clair
il ne s'est pas que j'ai tellement une
question sur la mienne d'être d'identité
mais je trouve ça intéressant de se
poser des questions sur sa propre
féminine féminité en tant qu'homme et
j'ai voulu ce spectacle un petit peu
comment dire j'ai pas voulu tomber en
gros t'es sq est jeune très réussie elle
est très féminine mais ça pourrait être
un trans femmes comme ça pourrait être
une femme c'est à vous de choisir comme
ça vous fait du bien
vous l'avez créez comment à partir de
quoi alors au départ à partir de
simplement le titre même madame fraises
je pensais que c'était une bonne idée
pour trancher et
et switcher sur
madame fraises racontée par monsieur
fraize oui sauf que monsieur fraize
j'avais j'avais 20 ans et je dans les
pattes et il fallait que je le fasse
taire même si c'était pas forcément un
bavard mais madame fraises d'abord et
puis après tout les envies de
d'aujourd'hui que j'avais en tant que
comédien et surtout les fraises été
menée par rapport à mes vingt premières
années d'existence ce que j'avais
ressenti vécu et là c'était les vins
après des années suivantes beaucoup en
couple donc
j'apprenais à vivre avec une femme
voilà et puis bon c'est plus teinté de
s'était plaint de femmes mais je
m'inspire aussi des hommes
qui ont des sensibilités autour de moi
et
voilà est alors juste une dernière chose
c'est que c'est le
cgd jolies petites chaussures rouges qui
sont les mais je crois qu'un
personnage n'est aussi beaucoup par
rapport aux costumes et il est réalisé
par une nana qui s'appelait sarah dupont
qui est
la robe et le costume la perruque et
tout ça une fois qu'on le porte le
personnage prend totalement naissance
après il faut le laisser ce qui l'habite
qu'est-ce qui est par exemple l acea
spectacle sur l'étirement du temps elle
met un temps fou pour rembobiner le fils
du micro ou pour remplir un verre d'eau
elle elle parle de moi j'ai eu
l'impression est la longe la vie c'est
elle qui emploie cette expression à
maman dit quand on vit à la campagne ça
allonge la vie
alors il ya inclus une chose un peu
commun avec monsieur fraize bcl le fait
différemment elle sait vous est venu
comment ça je représente a souvent
reproché que c'était lent effectivement
enfin reprocher dans le sens où ça se
fait pas normalement le spectacle il
faut il faut avancer sinon on perd le
spectateur
moi plus on me dit de faire quelque
chose moi je le fais plus je vais faire
le contraire la madame fraises elle a
encore ralenti un peu le rythme et je
trouve que c'est une bonne manière de
calmer un petit peu cette à cette époque
trop rapide donc donc moi en tout cas je
sur scène je trouve pas ça du tout trop
haut trop lent ah non je me disais on
étire le temps et les tirs le temps mais
c'est un parti pris et je dois dire que
ça fait partie de l'adn de ce que j'aime
sur scène
non c'est vrai qu'on ne leur reproche
pas c'est juste que ça assez singulier
et c'est ce qui prend très souvent les
spectateurs par surprise vous
connaissent pas encore c'est ce qui les
frappe en premier oui ça peut les rendre
un peu nerveux mais au départ je me
souviens du temps de monsieur fraize
enfin avant que ça devienne le énorme
succès et y en avait qui partait ouais
je l'aï toujours ce moment là où je me
disais ah là tu fais du bon travail
mais madame phrase elle elle fait un
petit peu plus l'unanimité parce qu'elle
est elle est gentille elle l a pas de l
est pas méchante les adorables elle est
belle et elle aimante dont elle veut du
bien même si elle travaille le spectacle
c'est aussi sur la connaissance c'est à
dire comme nous tous elle croit
connaître un sujet et on aborder inonde
d'innombrables et ils s'en foutent elle
brode et elle bouche les trous est ce
que en fait très souvent on ne connaît
pas très bien les sujets qu'on aborde et
pourtant il nous arrive d'être assez
péremptoire et on bouche les trous parce
qu'on n'a pas au fond et elle va presque
un art consommé dans ce domaine monsieur
fraize l'avait aussi mais ça ça vient du
fait que je ne suis pas journaliste donc
je ne connais pas mes sujets et je suis
comédien donc il faut que je fasse au
moins semblant de travailler ou semblant
d'apprendre et je crois que sur scène je
jeu
gélard de quand même de jeu 2-2
de combler les fils de fer de dire que
c'est improvisé ça c'est pas à profiter
ma dame fred serre que ce qui est
improvisé c'est ce qui va sortir de ma
bouche mais avoue s'est improvisé oui
encore en partant grosse partie oui
aujourd'hui c'est un spectacle est
naissant mais oui la porte il ya quand
même une forme c'est à dire que si je
retourne le voir dommage mais voir le
même nom batotel demain ou lundi je me
suis fait avoir mais
ce qui est en revanche beaucoup moins
improvisées c'est chaque c'est la nature
de ce personnage qu'est ce qu'elle a
envie de dire de quelle manière je suis
en train de toucher au but ça mettre un
petit peu un petit peu de temps mais
c'est tout ce qui compte et c'était le
cas pour monsieur fraize ce sera le cas
pour madame affret cyr que moi c'est le
personnage que je bichonne et justement
qu'est-ce qui vous fait rire dans ce
personnage celui là oui ce qui me fait
rire
c'est
son look mais c'est surtout que ce
personnage se permet de faire rire avec
des choses positives c'est une nouvelle
quand même une nouvelle
qui sombre maintenant mais je pense
vraiment pas qu'on pouvait faire rire
sans se casser la gueule ou qui a un
accident et ben finalement des fois il
suffit de sourire
pour ça que ça fasse plaisir et
qu'est-ce qui vous émeut shevell ce qui
m'émeut c'est qu'elle fait elle me fait
penser à ma mère et ma mère m'a m'a
toujours inspiré beaucoup de jolies
sentiment donc
je me suis fortement inspiré de 2,2 de
demain maman qui qui est à quatre tours
a toujours inspiré cette fameuse phrase
de jacques prévert qui dit il veut il
fallait au moins essayer d'être heureux
ne serait ce que pour montrer l'exemple
je trouvais toujours que c'était une
bonne formule marc fraises c'est
jusqu'au 17 octobre au théâtre du
rond-point à 18h30 du jeudi au dimanche
et ensuite dans toute la france merci
merci frédéric ac fraises
[Musique]
éric mouton vous êtes libraires et
expert en livres anciens et en originaux
de bande dessinée on commence par votre
image l'image que vous avez choisi pour
symboliser notre époque c'est un dessin
d'hergé évidemment alors il a une
particularité c'est que ça devait être
la couverture du lotus bleu un être que
ce dessin donc original bains raconte
new skies c'est le graal dans votre dans
votre métier c'est grave parce
qu'effectivement s'il s'agit d'un album
majeur pour hergé qui est un album pivot
à partir duquel il a changé un peu
salines le calicot commencé à se
documenter beaucoup plus
le
l'intérêt de l'image pour moi c'est
qu'effectivement on est sur un record
puisqu'il a été vendu en janvier dernier
pour plus de 3 millions d'euros cher
yann chez artcurial 3 million deux cent
mille vrai compris millions 175 4
soirées très bourrin dessins originaux
inde et afrique ce qui fait sa pause ça
le pose en concurrent de kandinsky
d'egon schiele ou de picasso sur ce type
de produits alors c'est pas tant le
record
moi qui m'intéressait sur cette image
mais le fait que ça pérennise le
l'avènement en fait d'un adoubement de
la bande dessinée dans le domaine
artistique vous travaillez ou c'est
simplement qu'ils aient suffisamment de
collectionneurs et de collectionneurs
qui ont de l'argent de musées aussi qui
ont de l'argent et c'est ce qui fait
qu'on arrive à des sommes pareilles les
au fond c'est pas tant la somme qui est
intéressante c'est là c'est la durée
c'est à dire qu'en fait on est ça si
vous mélangez le fait qu'ils aient des
collectionneurs susceptible de sortir
des sommes comme celle là de manière
répétée oui parce que pour le pôle dans
le cas des rejet il ya eu déjà plusieurs
sommations 1 million à dole et lyon 1 2
million 5 sur les sur les 20 dernières
années si vous ajoutez l'intérêt muséal
l'onction muséal ou institutionnels
l'exposition à vis des réseaux qui a
lieu au musée maillol actuellement la
très belle exposition pratt au musée
d'aquitaine
jean serre de manière le salon du livre
rare voilà qui qui va prendre place
entre le 24 et le 26 à paris dont
l'invité et la cité internationale de la
bande dessinée d'angoulême vous avez
effectivement d'un côté cet argent de
l'autre côté cette onction musée à
l'esat et intérêts institutionnels et
vous ajoutez un grand public un public
une base démocratique qui n'existe sans
doute pas dans d'autres domaines
artistiques plus élitiste parce que là
ça se fait sur un terreau qui
effectueront le terreau des albums qui
n'a rien à voir avec les salles des
ventes
albums 9 mai qui est aussi une des
locomotives de l'édition en france
notamment le salon international du
livre rare et d expert en objets d'art
c'est son intitulé complet se tient donc
du 24 au 26 septembre à partir de demain
donc sur les le champ de mars dans le
grand palais éphémère qu on ya installé
en attendant que le
grand palais ouvre ses portes vous le
voyez donc derrière moi ce grand palais
fait mr c'est la 33e édition avec votre
librairie la librairie métamorphose vous
faites partie des 170 exposants cette
bande cette année la bande dessinée tel
honneur
néanmoins vous étiez là déjà les années
précédentes à quoi ça ressemble ce salon
qui est le 3 le premier du monde dans
son domaine le plus grand serait qu est
ce qui s'y passe c'est la grande mince
c'est la grande messe principalement
pour le pour le livre ancien enfin livre
ancien et moderne
mais en fait pour le livre rare c'est
effectivement la grande messe annuelle
c'est le plus grand salon au monde il en
existe d'autres importants qui draine
beaucoup de populations beaucoup de
professionnels pensent à new york mais
c'est vrai que bon sur paris on a
effectivement avec le plus gros en terme
de en terme d'affluence
est en fait celui voilà la grande messe
parce qu'effectivement c'est le moment
où tous les libraires vont toiletter
leur leurs plus beaux bijoux leur pique
leurs trésors en manuscrit en livres
anciens en édition originale en livre
illustré alors on trouve aussi des
bijoux un oui alors ça c'est l'autre
version c'est à dire que c'est le salon
du livre rare et les égards on a vu les
d'objat donc effectivement à peu près
160 6 soit 170 stands de libraires et
une trentaine d'experts qui vont
effectivement pour le coup de tout
domaine
d'objets rares donc plus de la librairie
on n'est plus sûr de la bibliophilie
justement vous vous êtes vous mêmes
experts en
on va dessiner ouais pour faire co
comment comment comment devient expert
ès que ce qu'il suffit de bien connaître
la bande dessinée pour pouvoir dire
qu'on est expert alors c'est pas
ce n'est pas la seule chose et a
effectivement on peut tout à fait avoir
de très bonnes connaissances
sans être expert c'est le cas de la
plupart des grands collectionneurs qui
entraient qui travaillent voilà qu'ils
sont faits l'oeil pendant des années et
des années la partie expertise c'est
patent d'après moi c'est pas tant un
problème de compétence ou de
connaissances c'est un problème de
responsabilité c'est à dire c'est pour
dire à tel moment voilà telle chose
d'après moi avec tout le travail que je
peux avoir fait sur cette pièce c'est
vous dire que oui elle est bonne et de
prendre la responsabilité pour
l'acheteur pour le consommateur ce qui
n'est pas le cas autrement parce
qu'effectivement si vous achetez 107-100
cette expertise sans cette
authentification vous avez effectivement
le risque de ne pas pouvoir vous
retourner là la personne prend
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que les experts
sont assurés c'est effectivement parce
qu'on n'est pas omniscient
j'ai pas à vocation j'ai pas
l'immodestie de penser que je ne me
trompe jamais que je ne trouverai jamais
l'idée c'est effectivement de faire tout
le travail raisonnable avec les outils
dont on dispose de donner une réponse et
de l'assumer par rapport au rapport à un
client par exemple la planche que l'on
voit ici kiki et au salon
est ce que un expert parce qu'on a vu
beaucoup de travaux d'expertisé qui sont
effectués depuis le début du confinement
par internet à distance est-ce qu'on
peut expertise et une planche comme
celle ci
sur par internet me trouve forcément
l'avoir sous les yeux la touchez pas
d'accord il ya beaucoup de ventes les
avocats ou c'est d'ailleurs l'un des
grands enjeux les expertises aujourd'hui
et du marché de la en général pas
spécifiquement du livre ou de la bande
dessinée c'est effectivement le
développement des deux sites de vente
d'art mais basé un peu sur ce qui se
faisait sur e-bay c'est à dire entre un
client et un acheteur alors de plus en
plus aussi ont des experts et des
experts tout à fait compétent mais
effectivement
dans l'immédiat au mot en tout cas au
moment de l'achat il n'y a pas cette
possibilité
de la certitude parce que les experts ne
travaille que sur photos et donc sur
photos de deux ans dans les chartes des
maisons des chambres d'experts il faut
effectivement à voir la pièce sur la
sous les yeux une photo c'est utile pour
faire une estimation en disant ben voila
si cette place est bonne ça peut valoir
autant mais si vous n'avez pas s'il
n'avait pas l'objet en question vous
pouvez absolument pas vérifié oui
absolument pas donné leur expertise
réelle
quand vous voyez c'est juste à des
desseins de de
bilal qui était d'ailleurs assis à votre
place s'il passe il on la remet ça
qu'est ce qui fait sa valeur à votre
avis vous le connaissez pas ce cette
oeuvre là qui est au salon aussi de
forcément mais mais qu'est ce qu'on
regarde pour savoir d'abord si c'est si
intéressant que ça est ce que ça vous
voilà déjà pour ce qui va en normand
dessinée déjà la différence entre
l'original et la syrie ce qui existe
d'ailleurs sur le principe du monde de
l'art la différence entre un original le
monde dessiné ou une sérigraphie on
avait déjà bien entendu pas du tout les
mêmes les mêmes montants donc il faut
déjà regarder si la paix c'est original
ou pas ensuite selon l'auteur vous avez
comme cette un marché vous aviez vous
avez des côtes vous avez toutes sortes
et de panels de fourchette qui vous
permet de savoir à peu près vous allez
et après il faut regarder effectivement
il ya des différences bien entendu entre
les illustrations et les planches
originales planches rien étant une
matrice tiré d'un album est donc dans
ces cas là il va falloir regarder de
quel album il s'agit si c'est la bonne
ou la mauvaise période de l'artiste si
on avait enfin s'il ya de mauvaises
périodes
après regarder à l'intérieur de cet
album l'intérêt de la planche par
rapport à l'histoire parce qu'un vrai
collectionneur va les taper une deux
trois peut être quatre planches sur un
album qui on compte 40 ou 50
donc voilà il ya tout cet ensemble puis
après il ya le dynamisme de la planche à
la qualité de la finition donc tout ça
fait un prix par rapport à une cote une
crotte de nez je voudrais qu'on veut on
regarde une planche peu importe le
dessinateur une planche avec vue sur le
gaz non reviendra sur ce dessin de bus
parce que ça c'est c'est vous qui le
qu'il avait un voyage celui là mais
voilà une planche comme celle ci voilà
c'est tintin c'est c'est mon avis
les 7,3
ça ressemble au stade de tocards
exactement mais à toute première version
originale
j'imagine que j'en sois propriétaire et
je me suis quelqu'un avait eu l'idée de
faire 5 à picasso mais ça nécessitait il
s'était il avait fait un calcul simple
et s'était dit si je divise est bon
c'est un dessin de picasso si j'en
faisais des petits carrés d'un
centimètre je les vendrais chacun plus
cher que je devais vendre l'ensemble on
lui a dit oui mais malheureusement il
n'a pas le droit de détruire l'oeuvre
d'art là en l'occurrence si je décidé de
vendre case par case je ne détruirai pas
l'oeuvre d'art puisque l'oeuvre d'art
c'est chaque dessin ça n'est pas la
planche est loin comment vous
positionner à si vous positionner de
manière très classique par rapport à par
rapport à l'arrêt dès le moment où on
décide et où on a décidé que la bande
dessinée était le 9ème art vous êtes
face à une oeuvre d'art donc il ya une
intégrité ensemble oui mais là vous
dites c'est la planche l'intégrité moi
je pourrais vous dire c'est l'album donc
non non parce que ça les bras de la
casse alors selon les artistes ça peut
être des sapeurs de la casse d'ailleurs
tout simplement parce que les artistes
ne travaillent pas tous de la même
manière ils peuvent travailler par 2000
planches ou travailler par case
effectivement donc oui de toute façon
vous tous joué par rien ne vous empêche
sur le fond d'eux
de la découpe et encore une fois ça vaut
mieux financièrement de la vendre en une
fois plutôt bien l'aborder comme je vous
disais vous même il ya des planches qui
intéresse plus les collectionneurs que
d'autres ils veulent le climax de
l'album avait pour hergé pour hergé il
ya en fait
on est aussi en train encore une fois
sur un marché de la marché de l'art il
ya la rareté ce qui fait les prix des rg
aujourd'hui c'est effectivement
l'extrême rareté des pièces qui peuvent
circuler dans le thé et le savent et
l'autre oui parce qu'il est
historiquement major
voilà il a dit
l'élu c'est un des très rares artistes
internationalement reconnues l'ue est
acheté
par toutes les générations en plus par
toutes les générations dans tous les
pays donc c'est effectivement ce qui
explique la grande différence entre la
cote des rejets et celle de celles de
ses suiveurs même si les suiveurs vont y
en a cinq ou six sur le chemin qui
tiennent la corde qui sombre qui font
partie des grandes têtes de gondole
avant c'est sa manière de manière un peu
un peu vulgaire mais effectivement il ya
une grosse différence entre en entre ces
divers artistes mais genre à découper rg
je peux pas parler de sacrilège pas ce
parce que voilà tout tout tout peut se
faire tout peut s'expliquer
mais pour le coup ce serait ce serait si
on ne peut pas une bonne opération
financée voilà c'était la seule question
que je posais et d'autre part à quoi
ressemblent les bibliophiles de la bande
dessinée ceux qui veulent le livre rare
la planche rare dans la bande dessinée
c'est pas du tout le même monde que le c
pour ça ce que ça va être intéressant de
d'avoir mis cet éclairage sur la sur la
bande dessinée cette année au niveau du
salon du livre
parce que c'est vrai que le salon du
livre rare c'est un salon qui quand même
assez feutrée
il n'ya pas l'exubérance qu'on peut
avoir à la fiac ou d'en avoir au niveau
de l'art contemporain et bibliophilie
lourds ou un âge quand même vénérable
pour certains c'est que je serai assez
discret les voilà traiterait les
légendes cacher leurs trésors le mil la
bd pas du tout le même vous avez pour le
coup une ouverture complète de tous les
genres sociaux de tous les âges
il ya même pas cette limitation qu'on
peut avoir okon a vite sur le marché du
livre du livre ancien qui est celui du
prix parce que
la bd s'appuyant sur un sur une
production qui est quand même très
importante
permet d'avoir des entames ou des
ouvertures d'achat très raisonnable
pouvez vous faire plaisir avec quelques
centaines d'euros à condition pas
vouloir acheter du verger mais vous
pouvez le faire très facilement pour
beaucoup d'autres choses ce qui permet
justement d'avoir un public beaucoup
plus large beaucoup plus représentatif
de l'ensemble de la société et je
frappais dans les séances de dédicaces
qui se multiplient 1
alors les les auteurs de romans
dédicacent leurs romans et et à tous les
auteurs de bande dessinée on voit des
fils du considérable de femmes qui leur
demandent un dessin et ça leur prend
d'ailleurs un temps fou généralement
pour signer un
pur du mois pour d'abord dessiné un
dessin et ensuite le signer ça prend un
temps fou mais 12 ha sont des originaux
qui un jour ou l'autre peuvent arriver
dans votre votre lit bay et au salon mal
agi a malheureusement mal heureusement
pour ces artistes il y en a déjà pas mal
qui surgissent dès le lendemain sur le
sur le marché c'est à dire que sachant
que vous allez payer votre bande
dessinée 10 euros ou 20 euros
si vous la faites dédicacé par un auteur
couru même si la dédicace est assez
simple ça passe presque à 120 euros le
lendemain ce qui voit là ça va ça fait
sur la quantité a beaucoup d'argent mais
effectivement ça fait une très belle
culbute en 24 heures et il compte se
servir et des cinq je revois qui font
des vrais desseins oui ça se fait
beaucoup de sable mais malheureusement
ça se fait beaucoup c'est vrai que c'est
le côté un peu regrettable de deux de
ses fils attendait justement la
spéculation qui peut exister
occasionnellement parce que c'est vrai
que voilà le côté va un peu vite mais
oui bien entendu les dédicaces peuvent
arriver chez moi je vends des dédicaces
la difficulté c'est effectivement d'en
trouver qu'il ne soit pas qu'il soit
vraiment léché et représentatif du style
de l'artiste parce que c'est vrai que
bell est malheureux travail au kilomètre
sur les sur les salons donc c'est vrai
qu'à un moment il ya de la lassitude et
le trait n'est pas toujours aussi
efficace ou
agréable qu'il l'est à l'intérieur de
l'album ce qui se comprend tout à fait
et ça pourrait être aussi puisque la
rareté prime ça pourrait être un mauvais
dessin d'hergé par exemple
particulièrement raté ça pourrait être
par sa rareté même
vendu très cher ça pourrait intéresser
des collectionneurs je crois qu'on n'en
est pas encore là ça viendra mais on en
est pas encore là pour le moment le
marché le marché est un marché très
jeune
très structurée mais très jeune
et on est vraiment sur des sur des
suivis très classique des logiques très
classique vous allez avoir besoin par
exemple pour qu'une pour qu'une planche
vaille vraiment beaucoup d'argent
d'avoir le personnage central sur la
planche
potentiellement vous prenez une autre
planche de l'album meilleur
graphiquement mais où la tap
n'apparaîtra pas le héros
la valeur sera sans doute un peu
moindres pour le moment c'est à dire que
je crois qu'il ya encore beaucoup d
espace pour l'éducation esthétique
graphique
de dudu du public et du marché lui-même
temps des marchands que des acheteurs
pour réussir à aboutir à quelque chose
qui soit vraiment lié à l'appui
seulement à des choses trop visible a
donc quelque chose de raté oui ça va
pouvoir intéresser quelqu'un pour le
côté blizzard pour le côté particuliers
mais la majeure partie des
collectionneurs risque de sang de s'en
détourner oui et vous le disiez sait où
c'est d'abord et avant tout un salon de
de bibliophiles 1 donc on aime beaucoup
des éditions originales on aime beaucoup
les dédicaces en page c'est ce qui fait
la valeur d'un livre patrick modiano
célèbre écrivain et prix nobel
souvent raconté quand il était jeune il
vendait des éditions rares et donc sur
lesquels ils n'hésitaient pas à imiter
la signature de l'écrivain donc il doit
y avoir des faux
dédicace sur des livres à qui ont été
faites par bouziane aussi vous savez ça
pourrait peut-être augmenter leur bride
il ya là pour le coup elle inverse de ce
qu on disait tout à l'heure sur un
dessin raté
info fait pas à pas un écrivain reconnu
célèbre obligatoirement va avoir on se
retrouve sur le modèle de l'unique à
en livre en livre ancien justement la
pièce voilà la pièce très particulière
qui sera pour le coup je risque d'être
couru non seulement par le
collectionneur de modiano en
l'occurrence mais par des
collectionneurs d'unica parce que ça
peut être aussi une entrée de collection
y a des il ya eu beaucoup d'affaires de
faux en peinture en dessin mais est-ce
qu'il ya eu des affaires de faux en
bande dessinée est ce qui vous arrive de
vous retrouver avec une
planche ce qui est un faux info aux
aspects que c'est pas très difficile
d'imiter le style d'uderzo par exemple
il est où vous pourrez déjeuner qu'il ya
des gens qui ont ce qu'on reproduise des
défauts ce proche des 20,6 originale les
faux les faux existe toujours alors pour
le coup il ya toujours moyen il ya
toujours moyen de faire un faux de
planche sur une planche intégral c'est
plus difficile parce que c'est comme
tout vous allez avoir l'oeil a toujours
un moment le déséquilibre ou la main de
l'artiste va manquer il faut déjà ne
plus avoir le support il faudra un
papier il faut voilà il ya toutes ces
techniques là qui font que c'est plus
compliqué
après défaut sur des dédicaces il y en a
pas mal il y en a pas mal parce que
c'est ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure dès
le moment où
vous pouvez gagner quelques centaines de
retrait très vite avec un petit croquis
ont parlé des rejets une dédicace
d'hergé aujourd'hui
s'estimer en gérant salle des ventes en
général entre mille 2
on va dire mille 2005 ou 1000 1200 euros
sa part facilement aux alentours des
2000 et voulait retrouver de toute façon
chez les marchands souvent à 2000
parfois plus cher donc effectivement il
peut y avoir une tentation et le support
est pas nécessairement très compliqué à
trouver puisqu'il suffit de trouver un
album après sur le même principe il faut
quand même que l'encré ou le feutre mais
correspondent donc voilà c'est un
travail de contrefaçon c'est un travail
de contrefaçon mais c'est vrai que sur
le même principe que dans le manuscrit
il existe des faux c'est quand même plus
cohérent d'aller d'aller faire un faux
tableaux
de monnaie de pizarro en allant au qu c
on devra tous les pigments et en
retravaillant et en ayant vraiment tout
le matériel pour foire offert une pièce
à condition que ce ne soit pas une de
musées des scanner mais pour le reste
financièrement ça va être par rapport au
travail données et à la possibilité de
trouver le matériau pour le faire c'est
quand même plus facile après comme
toujours des moments où un marché a le
vent en poupe et génère 2 génère des
profits et de l'argent et une
spéculation vous avez obligatoirement
défaut sur le sur le marché
occasionnellement
il ya eu toute une série de faux point
sur l'exemple de retour de réserve ah
oui c'est vrai dans les années 2000 les
pièces qui étaient sortis des deux qui
sont sortis au plus petit à petit et
puis voilà qui ont été vendus vraiment
pas cher et puis qui petit à petit voilà
son grimper grimper grimper en prix
certaines d'ailleurs souvent de passer
en salle des ventes occasionnellement
parce que c'est vrai qu'après avec avec
lui ajoutant il suffit que ça passe une
fois pour avoir presque une sorte de
validation voilà mais ça a effectivement
oui il en existe
heureusement
heureusement c'est pas une c'est pas une
majorité c'est pas le marché n'est pas
criblé par les faux regardons le maul
bus qui sera sur votre stand pendant ce
salon du livre rare
qu'est ce qui fait son intérêt et sa
valeur alors l'intérêt la valeur
ça peut dépendre veux je vous ai parlé
des grilles du marché ça peut dépendre
d'un collectionneur à l'autre ou d'un
marchand à l'autre moi ce qui fait sa
valeur pour moi est ce qui ce qui m'a
poussé à ce qui m'a poussé à l'acquérir
c'est l'histoire qui va c'est l'histoire
qui va avec c'est à kourou guyane mille
façons de faire ce métier moi j'aime
bien parce j'aime bien transmettre une
histoire réduire le champ où le stock
des pièces mais sur les pièces sur
lesquelles il va y avoir quelque chose à
raconter
l'ast une pièce un peu particulière
parce qu'en fait elle a servi c'est une
des trois puits des trois dessins c'est
le plus petit l'air parce que là on le
voit très grand mais c'est une vignette
qui fait 4 par 7
qui a servi à illustrer
la sortie de l'express en
1979 et qui était un exemplaire spécial
express en 2001 donc en fait c'est un
express
futuriste avec que la liste que des faux
articles de ce que serait l'année 2001
et avec un article sur la mode
qui était illustré sur un défilé de mode
qui était illustré par moïse bus il y
avait justement des choses un petit peu
prophétique alors ça n'explique pas
nécessairement parce que c'est là on est
complètement dans la dans la main de mon
église dans la meilleure main de la
haute époque du star watchers mais il ya
une petite explication qui est donnée
par pas par la tique qui est un petit
clin d'oeil qui effectivement de dire
que dans le futur les cadres les cadres
irons chercher la mode dans le monde
assyriens et les leurs femmes du côté du
tchador iranien donc c'est censé être
voilà une vision 2000 bus de du tchador
alors c'est vrai qu'ils sont beaucoup
plus de légèreté à l'époque même si en
79 ans d'être déjà sur des affaires
iraniennes avec la révolution mais voilà
le discours est peut-être un peu plus un
peu petit pesant aujourd'hui par rapport
à ça
voilà sur cette histoire là moi c'est
vrai que c'est une saignée elle vend
plus on a vraiment la perfection sur une
toute petite pièce de la grande capacité
de moby sur du génie le mauvais bus qui
en fait justement d un des quelques
artistes
avec une cote très international quand
on parle de
livres rares ou de dessins originaux pas
ce qui lui est le plus la cote dans le
monde de la bande dessinée vous l'avez
dit serge et c'est le graal absolu ce
que tout le monde cherche c'est ça qui
sont les autres alors bien entendu comme
vous étiez un peu une auberge c'est un
peu une auberge espagnole donne
effectivement il ya un panel très large
de choix et donc il peut y avoir
énormément d'entrées collection sur le
marché on est sur
presque presque l'école des six heures
j'ai pas parler la musique parce que ce
que moins connu du grand public mais
vous avez effectivement bon hergé uderzo
à franquin
bilal prat et aliments manque un mois et
demi voilà qui se regroupe pratt oui
hugo pratt aussi hugo pratt oui parce
que hugo pratt et hugo pratt est vital
vital dans l'histoire de la de la bande
dessinée
en partie avec sa fin avec sa façon de
sa trame narrative qui est très
personnelle un trait qui est très
personnel aussi qui a fait beaucoup
d'émules
qui est très littéraire et qui en plus
apporté énormément choses on en parlait
tout à l'heure pour fois réussir à
changer l'image de la bande dessinée qui
était longtemps cantonné à une
littérature enfantine c'est vrai que
pour le passage un vrai vecteur culturel
des auteurs comme comme hugo pratt sont
vitaux sachant qu'en plus il est arrivé
en france par le biais de pif gadget qui
était l'hebdomadaire des oui les enfants
malades oui mais pas pilote qui touchait
les adolescences une énorme et c'est par
les enfants c'est vrai que
malheureusement c'est resté longtemps
comme ça c'est resté longtemps comme ça
notamment en partie à cause de la de la
loi de 46
voilà qui voulait encadrer la lan pour
la reconstruction morale éviter la
paresse qui allait apporter la bande
dessinée on a effectivement c'est vrai
c'est très cantonné pendant très
longtemps la bd était quelque chose
d'enfantin de pas très sérieux prades
fait partie des auteurs qui justement
son sort ont réussi à sortir de cet
enfer
à force de scénario vraiment très très
bien construit ils sont vraiment réels
roma littérature c'est parce que c'est
du roman graphique en partie va alors
après les discussions autour du roman
graphique sont très larges mais on est
effectivement sur quelque chose avec
différents degrés de lecture très
poétique très graphique narratif très
historiens parce qu'il y avait
effectivement énormément de recherches
et le manque de documentation mais de
manière ludique donc on a grâce à un
très très bel ensemble ce qui explique
la cote de du coprah d'aujourd'hui mais
uderzo par exemple vous citiez il ya eu
beaucoup d'événements autour de l'idée
du des réseaux ces derniers temps
j'imagine qu'un dessin d'uderzo une
planche d'uderzo
dans les astérix scénarisé par rené
goscinny ça vaut plus cher qu'une
planche d'uderzo dans un astérix
scénarisé par uderzo ou scénarisé par
les scénaristes qui ensuite au succès
des interviews ou pas ce que c'est
toujours un dessin d'uderzo oui et non
pas exactement oui et non ça devrait
voilà par rapport aux canons ça devrait
mais c'est vrai que encore une fois on
est sur un degré de rareté donc temps
que vous avez la main d'uderzo il
faisait astérix dans la case vous partez
vous partez effectivement sur les choses
alors que pendant très longtemps et
encore quelques années enfin le même la
côte du gazeau a explosé en deux trois
ans parce qu'il ya quelques pièces
justement qui sont arrivés sur le marché
qui ont permis justement de se rendre
compte que quel que soit le moment enfin
que si vous les estimé 50 60 80 100 elle
finissait aux alentours de 10 ans au
minimum et il finit par y avoir un
lissage
encore faut-il qu'ils les pièces qui
arrivent sur le marché donc
effectivement bien entendu bien entendu
les
bon l'idéal ce serait ce serait d'avoir
assez riche et légaux parce que si je me
souviens bien c'est cet album là dans
toutes les planches ont disparu ah oui
car on sait que voilà c'est là pour le
coup ce serait un miracle on aurait paru
ça veut pas dire qu'elles ont été
détruites non parce que c'est comment à
l'ère des des originaux de céline
exactement d'autres viennent se rendent
compte exact on les croyait disparue
voire même qu'il n'avait jamais existé
et en fait ils réapparaissent ils
réapparaissent oui là avec avec avec
rebond et avait beaucoup de voile avec
beaucoup de complicité lie à pas la même
histoire il n'a pas fallu désosser
jamais contrairement à céline n'a jamais
parlé d'avoir été dérobés y a pas eu
tous les walis appelle surtout modèle 1
to cheminement qui existent pour ses
manuscrits de céline aujourd'hui mes
vidéos on voit je tenais cet exemple là
c'est juste pour pour augmenter le degré
de rareté mais encore une fois sur le
marché les planches 2 0 sont déjà très
très rare donc qui a pas effectivement
besoin de pousser plus loin la
difficulté dans la recherche et l'achat
dans le cas de céline pour terminer il
avait dit voilà tout ce qu'on m'a volé
pendant que j'étais parti au danemark
comme on les avait jamais revu on
s'était dit bombe a peut-être qu'il a
exagéré aujourd'hui on s'aperçoit que
c'est là on les a pas encore lu parce
que ça n'a pas encore été édité mais à
pas nous on sait que c'est là vous êtes
pas dit tiens si ça se trouve cette info
on savait très bien ce qui manquait
puisque céline nous l'avait dit
quelqu'un aurait pu depuis la
disparition de céline ce serait bien à
faire c'est faux vous n'êtes pas poser
la question tant qu'expert non mais dès
que quelqu'un essaye d'imiter céline non
ils essayent de nous faire là pour lever
ce n'est pas que j'avance je me suis
même pas posé la question parce que
l'information m'est tombé dessus un peu
voilà un peu un peu par accident mais je
me suis auto moment de poser la question
que j'ai eu l'information immédiatement
avec la quantité de documents qui ont
été trouvés donc je crois qu'il ya un
mètre cube de ma des manuscrits
à les copier un mètre cube de manuscrits
du temps et je sais pas j'imagine que
vous connaissez l'écriture de ces lignes
a recopié céline en manuscrit il est
déjà très difficile à déchiffrer où il
peut être sûr en tout cas sur ces
premiers jets et moi j'ai eu quelques
premiers jets sous l'assaut sous les
yeux
c'est un vrai travail de fond il faut
vraiment réussir à marans est une
habitude vous rentrez dedans une fois
vous êtes rentré dedans vous retrouver
ou son voilà pourquoi les passages à la
2 pourquoi il ya des contractions
pourquoi des fouilles pourquoi séparer
mais c'est vrai qu'au départ c'est un
peu rebutant et donc j'imagine que pour
le coup si un faussaire a vérifié faire
un mètre cube de fossilise et en plus
avec le style jeudi de toute façon il
mérite le budget de l'argent qu'il aura
trouvé
merci eric mouton vous serez donc au
grand palais à partir de demain jusqu'au
26 septembre
pour le salon des livres rares et des
objets d'art et puis sinon la librairie
ses métamorphoses qui se trouve rue
jacob merci merci de nous avoir suivis
et rendez vous au prochain numéro merci
à vous
[Musique]